to present the award for the best  performance by a supporting actor we  have chosen two people who reach one  more Oscars than anybody how vulgar huh  however with starch lip I'll carry on  you aren't here any hissing over the  following applause that'll be me ladies  and gentlemen  betty davis and anthony quinn right here  Madam President will you throw out the  first nomination with pleasure  the first nomination for the Best  Supporting Actor is Theodore Bikel in  the Defiant ones lee jae carve and  brothers karamazov well I'm a big  country  Arthur Kennedy and some came running gig  young in teacher's pet you have the  envelope tune their lives in the big  castle  I'd like to thank the members of the  Academy especially was thank Willie  Wyler Gregory Peck sy Bartlett and Jim  Webb for the nice words they wrote and  all of the rest of the company and the  crew of the big country  you